foreign
[Music]
on this channel
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the baby games we've got
it all for you the struggles
oh the intensity the triumphs first up
gymnastics
the American
working it
just look at that concentration
10 meter total one of the Marquee events
at any baby game and there they go
China running away with it
oh looks like he's stuck on the line and
here comes Argentina on the outside
but China does it for gold
back to gymnastics Japan on the Rings
pressure has never been higher
[Applause]
effort
I'm sorry I'm sorry the close-up of the
baby faces be killing me the
concentration woman didn't do nothing
she just stood there just look at that
concentration
does she looked late
she looked like she was concentrated she
was concentrating and taking [ __ ] right
because you know babies be [ __ ] like
that while they're looking at you yeah
you ever seen it is how was it
it was wrong can you just [ __ ] and
they're like we met not right now
yeah yeah what are you gonna show I
can't believe this happened
what do you think about California
you like it yeah do you like it
you taking a [ __ ]
[Music]
laughs
this is a gooey
oh my God
oh [ __ ]
oh
Jesus
oh my God
okay
[Laughter]
all right
oh I think it's the first time I cried
on this channel
[Laughter]
what do you think about California
and you know what I think I feel the
same way when I think about California
I [ __ ] hate Los Angeles
not all of it some parts are amazing oh
my God the way that kid started [ __ ]
yo Charlie be making me feel like I
wanna [ __ ] that's fun that's one of the
greatest videos of all time oh man
California
the way this kid shot on you wasn't more
the video that's it no that's it
I'm sorry that was amazing that's
amazing I appreciate thank you
yo that's you got me dying bro
okay all right that's good appreciate
that contribution oh my God
just look at that no
all right all right let's go let's do
this oh all right here we go yeah
today's video brought to you by raycon
the gels these earbuds the gels on them
they do not budge you stick them in here
they're not falling out an almost custom
comfortable fit they offer eight hours
of play time and 32 hours of battery
life when I'm flying and I gotta take
these long hauls and all these different
connecting flights I'd pop these in with
me and they last throughout the whole
trip and so I can go to sleep peacefully
not to have to listen to any babies on
the flights plan it's just so nice
listen this is the holiday season you
got to think about what you got to buy I
make it easy we're tired of wired
headphones you pop them around you slide
don't work and the other competitors far
too expensive we offer the premium sound
at half the price so you already know
what to do for this holiday season get
you some raycons click the link in the
description box or go to buy recon.com
to get 15 site-wide with the promo code
holiday there'll also be new pop-up
deals every day during raycon's
countdown to Christmas and I'll try to
keep the description box updated with
each one of those latest deals by
supporting raycon you'll be supporting
us so you know what it is we all helping
each other out get some good sound
support us everybody's happier now the
Americans
the Dismount nailed it
gold for the U.S yo dead ass if this was
real I'd watch this
I wouldn't I would pause I would
watching the best babies compete oh man
just to see the freak Show no we're not
you know like a freak Show no okay leave
a comment below would you guys watch
something like this if they had babies
from all over the world think about it
there's a bunch of countries I might
want to win for once that were never
competitive think of Mongolia what if
Mongolia got the best babies and we
don't know maybe that's what I'm trying
to say
no yeah
it's hot over the weightlifting
Argentina can they do it
that kid's not from Argentina no he's
not see a lot of argentinians not one of
them comes in these Dark Shades they
don't look like that my man got nappy
hair and I'm saying there's no nappy
folks out there in Latin America well
I'm a man
got that West African genetics like some
of his ancestor did some voodoo
shall we
that Arkansas
why is he crying why is he crying
because they said he's from Argentina
then they do it
laughs
oh and it's a heartbreaking result
[Music]
now the German just Showboat it
that babies
[Laughter]
now on to our final event the three
hurdle toddle
there they go
a little unorthodox
France having some trouble on the last
hurdle
[Applause]
oh and it's incredible it's gold for
France watch all your favorite Olympic
moments on the Olympic Channel
the games Never End let's get guys
[ __ ] shoot his head
I I like that I liked it ways I I
thought it was a funny video it's a
little entertaining but but please
actually killed
I should kill I'm not even called fret
too
oh man
if [ __ ] I knew it was coming it [ __ ]
me up oh yeah some things just never
stopped being funny it's like oh my God
no actually I would like to see free no
not babies but because
we talk about the Olympics and stuff
like that uh I never got to compete
because I injured myself
and we don't even know if I would have
been good at it or anything like that
I've never been able to do that but
and when I got bad
everybody was on like some enhancement
tips all the time and even in high
school I remember that some people had
that mentality where like there was
still
they would steal their grandparents or
their parents pumps asthma pumps yeah
and they would puff up before
uh
uh what does that does it's supposed to
expand your lungs that doesn't matter if
it works or not if it's a myth or not
where it's going to do that if you don't
have asthma expands your lungs or
whatever whatnot it doesn't matter
you're you're thinking it works you you
don't you're thinking of using something
to cheat you're using a drug to cheat
just that
and that was there in high school
there's some people that you they use
this different type of drugs and stuff
like that in a high school I remember
that and then after that you go into the
open world where you do open
competitions where people to get
classified to do other things use
steroids and then after that I stopped
using so whenever they're supposed to do
the test they don't they don't fall into
that whatever blah blah right
and one of my favorite well my idol was
Bruno and I didn't want to use anything
like that just to be like him
um and
uh yeah it never and then whatever
yeah that dream never happened and stuff
like that so but I would like to see
like the Olympics I think the Olympics
should not just be them competing I want
to see them compete
but then on the side I want to see a
normal ass human being
how much
more efficient are they like the 100
meter dash yeah you run it in nine in
nine seconds nine something
even that that's like that's a lot but
you're running in 10 seconds
um or under 10
that's cool but I want to be able to
understand how fast much of a machine
these people are you're right I want to
put a normal human being to run next to
them I will watch that okay to watch
like the normal because everybody's like
everybody's talking [ __ ] oh yeah go
faster go faster and then you put a
normal human being this to that person
and you realize that a second is is long
when you're talking about speed a second
is a whole lot of time so I I would
watch I would watch that but babies
let us know what you guys think which
one you guys watch you watch The
Preacher's version or my version with
the babies let's know what you guys
think